borderline not processing how happy i am
that we are all back together
i was watching the trailer for season
two and i couldn't stop laughing who was
that he was clearly hitting on you i
thought my days of being attracted to
straight men were behind me and yet here
we are what's the vibe like on set with
such talented women
it is so funny we are all very similar
to our characters even when we come out
of like what we just did on a weekend
like couldn't be more different like kat
and brenda came and they like picked
vegetables from their garden
you have too many plants astronauts i
have like some crazy story about what we
did it's just so different and it's fun
to always be you know together and
another lady bringing the fun is none
other than lily singh lily joins the
cast of doll face as liv a queer bar
owner who explores a business and
romantic relationship with shae's
character stella i immediately like you
not just cause i hope you can get me a
drink
go ahead we're doing a fun self-service
thing obviously we are both canadians
yeah we have a lot of understanding
amongst us but she's just so talented it
was sort of the perfect fit for my
character to play opposite of i have
never been happier stella has always
been a very fluid character and so i
think having liv's character be on there
it wasn't really like a huge to do
it just you know happened and then they
fell for each other and it was nice to
really portray that story